one that sexual assault is a widespread
systemic problem that affects women
everywhere and to the Liberals did it
here at the opposition we are experts in
survivalism and bunker living which is
why given our current toxic environment
of sexual harassment the shop position
is proud to offer the bunk her the bunk
her a solo bunker for women so that men
can be protected from the sex feelings
you give them by existing when a dude
consents that a woman is living inside
the bunker the bunker will automatically
lock it down until that poor guy's boner
goes away and don't worry hey there's a
woman earlier promiscuous models were
perfected after several trial run just
watch it in action the bunker stealth
mode can save this man from his own
inappropriate jokes
thanks bunker when that hard steel
exterior just isn't enough for those
extra sexy days and your coworker can
still tell there's a human woman inside
extra measures kick in to protect him
from himself never have a dull moment
living your life in the bunker the
inside is equipped with everything a
woman could need scrapbooking supplies
and a scale yeah you in the bunker a
girl you still need to get you a husband
and the outside can be bedazzled to suit
your personal style just don't do too
much girl then you'll be asking for it
because it's like my dude Don jr. said
women who can't handle harassment don't
belong in the workforce okay this is our
word problem ladies man can't be
expected to stop but women are expected
to change in our eye Laura